well a sharp object could be painful
money is certainly not painful what up
though it's your boy big snoop dog
double g hi everyone welcome we're
hosting snoop and martha's very tasty
halloween but right now i'm about to
play can you guess
these spooky phobias
what are you afraid of if you have
ikemophobia
money sharp objects or math
well a sharp object could be painful
math is not painful and money is
certainly not painful correct sharp
objects the fear of math that's my
answer
the next one
arachnophobia is it a fear of hockey
pimples or spiders
it's spiders
i've seen that movie arachnophobia
so i'm going to say spiders
cool rhophobia either cauliflower
colors or clowns
i'd say
clowns
my little brother george he hated clowns
so much from an early age it's clowns
correct
i'm doing well phonophobia are you
afraid of kombucha i don't think so
afraid of ikea i don't think so i'd say
buttons
buttons
rich buttons oh nyctophobia nyc to
phobia
new york city
clocks or the dark
all of these things you could be really
afraid of
the dark
should i take the hint as
new york city
wrong
it's the fear of the dark ophediophobia
pda
public displays of infection feet or
snakes more people are afraid of snakes
than any others of these so it must be
snakes correct
see right again
[Music]
snakes
sam henophobia you're afraid of public
speaking you're afraid of halloween or
you're afraid of sleep could it be
halloween no nobody's afraid
nobody's afraid of public speaking
i would say
public speaking
afraid of sleep wrong
halloween
five out of seven which is pretty bad
i did score better than 33 percent of
all other quiz takers but not good
enough i should have a hundred i'm
martha thank you buzzfeed now i want
y'all to go check out snoop and martha's
very tasty halloween special streaming
only on pika
[Music]
you